2-0-1.
SO FAR, THE DEVEV IN THE BLANKS
MOVE ALONG.
MASONJONAS SIEGENTHALER UNDER
PRESSURE AND SUBBAN ON THE STICK
OF YEGOR SHAHA
THE TEAMS THIS YEAR.
SHARANGOVICH MANEUVERS INTO THE
THE CAPS.
DANIEL SPRONG, AND A NICE
DEFENSIVE E ED SHOT PLAYING THE
LEFT SIDE.
AND HAMILTON COVERS UP HIM.
SO SOMEBODY'S GOT TO STOP RIGHT
IN FRO
DEVILS WITH THE THIRD ACROSS, A.
THAT'S A NICE PLAY BY ORLOV AS .
JOHN CARLSON, THEKING GOOD
AND FINGERS CROSSED HE COULD
NET.
THE CAPITALS REALLY HAD A ON TH
SEE IF
FAR TOO OFTEN WE HAVE SEEN SO
FAR IN THIS SECOND PERIOD,,
>> Ken: DEVILS LOOKING ON THEHE
>> Steve: HAMILTON SEES SPRONG,
BURSTS IN.
SPRONG SHOTS.
HE SCORES.
WATCH THE QUICK HANDS HERE.OPPO.
>> Ken: DEVILS NEED A GOAL HERE,
CANG,
THAT'S WHERE IT IS AN ADVANTAGE
A RIGHT-HANDED SHOT ON THE LEFT
SIDE THAT YOU CAN GET THAT
ONE- WAY TO
SCORE.
YOU REMEMBER LAST YEAR, CANG,
THEY CAME BACK ON TET A
GOAL AND MAYBE THINK THEY HAVE
AN OPPORTUNINI OWN BATTERING.
GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
WAS AN OPPOR
GOOD FORECHECK BY
GEERTSEN.
AND
DEVILS OUT TO CENTER.
KUOKKANEN.
HAS ZACHA WITH HIM.
THE THIRD OPTION, SEVERSON CITI
OF CANADA AND GERMANY..
THEY S S KUZNETSOV.
SOMEHOW NOT A WHOLE LOT TO SHOOT
AT.
>> Steve: CENTERING TRY FOR
MERCER.
O MERCER
IN THE SLOT, BUT KUOKKANEN GF TT
IS NOT WHAT YOU
TO